《股票大作手回憶錄》這本書,
可以說是股票交易者一本經典書,
這本書和絕大多數市面上那些股票成功學不太一樣,
它主要是講人性,
它講思考,
它講的是一種失敗的經歷,
描述失敗的這種書籍實在是太少太少了,
這類書籍遠比那些所謂的成功學來得更有價值。
所以今天我打算開一個專題,
聊一聊著名的股票大作手Jesse Livermore的一些感悟,
挑選他的一些經典的語句,
來結合我自己的一些經驗,
來分享一些我自己的看法。
利弗莫爾說
華爾街沒有新鮮事
投機像山月一樣古老
那股市上今天發生的事
過去發生過
將來也必然會再次發生
這段話裡面呢
其實道出了一個本質
叫什麼呢
人之本性是趨利避害的
那麼我們接觸過很多
新進入市場的一些投資者
一些交易者
他們很多人都幻想著
什麼說呢
上漲的時候
這個時候都有它的份,下跌的時候它最好就已經不在了
或者說是漲之前買入,跌之前賣出,這種心理狀態
這種心理狀態本質上就是叫做趨利避害
市場之所以有規律可循,我們說就是因為是人性根股不變
某些關鍵的價格,某些關鍵的位置上出現集體性的
它會觸發集體性的趨利避害的行為
這就使得我們有跡可循
這就是市場規律
所以才印了這一句話
叫做今天發生的事
過去發生過
將來也一定會發生
這就是市場規律
應該說我們交易的是什麼
我們交易的就是人性
當然有經驗的交易者
有經驗的投資者都知道
股市裡是沒有辦法
做到完全的趨利避害的
很多時候
我們要想獲得一個比較大的一個收益
就必須要忍受一定程度上的這種賬面損失
有時候也要煎熬相當長的一段時間
這是成本
它也是代價
因此我做交易的兩個基本原則
一個叫做什麼
叫做盈虧同源
那麼另外一個叫做盈虧比
每做一筆交易
這一筆交易進去
在我的腦海裡頭是沒有勝算之說的
都是盈虧各佔50%
那麼我只能說
我儘量去找那種
能夠觸發人性趨利避害的
那些關鍵位置
能夠有比較大的盈虧比
一旦是我做對了
我的盈面非常大
我能賺很多
那麼萬一我做錯了
我損失很少的這種位置
這樣的去做
相當於是什麼呢
相當於是把我的一種風險
風險回報比做到最優
利文摩爾說
說,
長爹總有原因,
我14歲的時候就從不問為什麼長爹,
我現在40歲了,
我依然不問。
這段話呢,
其實我自己也有我自己的一個解讀,
那就是不聞不問,
這個市場上總有一些事情我們不知道。
因此,搞清楚為什麼,你真正搞清楚的可能都是歷史了,對於當下來說毫無用處。
對於當下來說
當發生了一些事情
不要問為什麼
最重要的是考慮好怎麼辦
這就要求我們要有計劃
我們要有各種各樣的計劃
應對不同的可能出現的情況
要做推演
要對未來做一個大致的估算
完了以後要有多個方案
也就是說出現什麼情況怎麼辦
你要有A計劃B計劃和C計劃
因此不聞不問
學會動態做推演
想好出現什麼情況
怎麼辦
立即採取行動
而不是等待搞清楚原因
再動手
有些股票會莫名原因裡
出現一些不尋常的漲跌
這是我們第一時間
可以看到的事實
是結果
也許收盤以後
或過一段時間
你會看到相應的報道
這是以後的事情
原因比事實遲到了很多
市場上總有一些先知先覺的人
他們總有他的信息渠道
他們有一些優勢等等方面
那麼也會有一些叫做後知先覺的人
那麼先知先覺的人
帶動後知先覺的人來
第一時間
他們算是第一時間做出反應的人
他們的行動一定會在市場上留下各種各樣的跡象
留下他們的痕跡
這就是所謂的出現一些不同尋常的漲跌
那麼所以我在我的這個交易的這個理念
或者說是交易系統當中呢
我非常重視市場的一些重要的跡象
比如說大量缺口
那麼某些關鍵位置突破前的一些異常的情況
比如說均線多頭排列
或者說是不可避免的交叉
這些事情都是用來觀察市場動向的一些重要的跡象
在交易高手的詞典裡面是沒有原因reason這個詞的
而是另外一個詞叫做驅動力或者叫做催化劑
英文叫做catalyst
catalyst的目的是讓市場產生反生性
要讓更多的人相信這個事情是這樣的
所以市場就有了更多的動力
也就是說catalyst的主要目的是讓市場形成自我強化
於是自我強化能形成一個趨勢
因此利弗莫爾說
立即採取行動
而不是等待搞清楚原因後再動手
這句話至關重要
這就是我以前我也經常說這麼一句話
叫做當你看見了一些跡象
看到了一些不同尋常的現象的時候
你必須在第一時間做出反應
叫trade what you see
很多時候交易是來自於一種
一種怎麼說呢
靈感
它是來自於長期的嚴謹的訓練下面
有時候會產生一種直覺
說實話
我的交易生涯當中
無數次被我的直覺所拯救
或者說是
我有時候也是為自己一些直覺交易
感到很驚訝
在市場出現信號之前
不要出手
我失誤的原因
主要是不能堅持自己的交易原則
頻繁的交易是導致虧損的主要原因
我想這段話
在股市中有閱歷的人
都會有一些體會
應該說很多時候
交易的失敗往往不是技術性的
不是不知道
也不是沒有事先的計劃
也不是不知道應該怎麼辦
而是情緒影響之下導致的一種誤操作
或者是叫做情緒影響了智商
另外就是由於太過豐富的想象力
會讓人情不自禁的去猜行情
今天在漲
那麼明天會不會漲呢
今天漲這麼多
明天會不會跌呢
今天跌這麼多
明天會不會反彈呢
人會有一種這種不由自主的
去偏離實際情況去猜去賭
這是萬萬要不得的
因此在市場沒有出現一些標誌性的動作
一些關鍵的跡象之前
最好的動作就是不動
很多時候人一旦有了一個猜想
一旦你的思想錨定在這一個猜想上
比如說今天大跌
明天會不會反彈呢
一旦你腦海裡頭冒出了這麼一點點反彈
要去抄底的念頭的時候
你的行為已經就缺乏彈性了
假設明天不反彈繼續跌
你根本就無法做出及時的反應
因此千萬千萬
不要去發揮你的想象
千萬千萬不要去猜
不要去賭
一定要讓自己的交易
讓自己的行為
讓自己的情緒
保證在一個最佳的狀態
保持在最有彈性的狀態
讓你自己的交易系統
處在一種比較
怎麼說呢
叫做高度容錯的狀態下面
所以新手的一個特點
最大的問題吧
應該說就是太過敏感
對一些小東西特別特別敏感
還有呢就是太過勤奮
總是要做點什麼
其實叫做什麼呢
不見兔子不撒鷹
獵物沒有一點動靜
沒有任何風吹草動的情況下
其實最好的辦法就是不動
該幹嘛幹嘛
休息去
不需要時時刻刻盯著市場的
股市上只有贏家和輸家
除此之外再無其他
俗話說凡事皆有兩面性
但股市只有一個面
既非牛市的一面
也非熊市的一面
而是正確的一面
這段話我實際上用了很長的時間才悟到
什麼叫做把事情做對
那這也是我經常說的
不要太在意盈虧
儘量把事情做對
那麼什麼叫把事情做對呢
兩件事
第一要有計劃
第二要按計劃行事
這兩件事相當於一個人的兩條腿
它必須是協同走的
你不能一條腿走路
即使做錯了
你可以不斷的修改
不斷的迭代
不斷的修正
完了以後讓你的這個
你的這兩條腿的走路姿勢
做到一種最優化
最協調
無限接近正確
但是如果說沒有計劃
或者說你有計劃
不按計劃行事
那你就無法去協調
無法去修正和迭代
讓它去進步
簡而言之
如果你是一個
每筆交易前都願意
花一點時間去做計劃的人
並且你在不斷的實踐過程當中
不斷的去迭代
修正你的這些交易邏輯
和你的計劃
長遠來看
你必定是個贏家
失敗的教訓讓我明白一個道理
只有當我確信自己不會賠錢時才出手
而如果我不能確信一定賺錢
那我就按兵不動
出手後發現不對
必須及時止損
必須果斷
這段話呢
我有我自己的理解
那麼首先股市裡沒有確定性
沒有人能夠確定自己一定不賠錢
沒有人能做到
但是某一些位置
或者說是某一些特殊的一種形態
如果說這個形態出現了變化
如果行情按照我希望的方式走出來
我可能會賺很多
而萬一行情不按照我的思路走
走反了
那麼我止損認錯出來
我的這個虧損很小
這就叫做什麼
叫做高盈虧比的位置
另外還有比如說是多週期共振的位置
一旦說是成功了
這個行情反轉了
或者是行情突破了
則會在多個週期裡面
同時打開空間
這種位置都是值得去交易的位置
這種位置機會都是很難得的
要耐心等待獵物靠近
等待機會
等待的是什麼機會呢
等待的就是這個機會
當然了
即便如此
我們雖然說廟堂之算
我們算了很多
結果呢
萬一這個行情沒有按照我們的思路在走
那麼這也沒什麼
那任何這種我們說叫做盈虧同源
你即使算得很清楚
你想得很明白
進去以後
你還是要做好失敗的這種準備的
因此我就有一個叫做
交易三問這麼一個東西
就是說
為什麼做這一筆交易
這就是說
逼迫我們去思考
我們這一筆交易的邏輯是什麼
我的計劃是什麼
比如說我是因為這個關鍵位置
因為一個盈虧比很高的位置
我要去做這一筆交易
好
既然你打算做這一筆交易
馬上第二個問題就是說
你的預期是什麼
那麼我預期這個位置如果說得到突破
那麼上行空間大概有百分之多少
那麼萬一這個突破不成功
或者說是失敗了
那麼接下來呢
我要止損
那麼止損位置空間是多少
這個盈面除以虧面
大概的這個盈虧比是多少
你看這就是盈虧比就算出來了
那麼也就是說
先搞清楚為什麼做這筆交易
第二個搞清楚你的預期是什麼
然後搞清楚你的底線是什麼
算出盈虧比
那麼就好
不達預期
也沒有跌破底線
那怎麼辦
你就拿著不動
那麼達到預期
對線走人
跌破底線
止損走人
這就是紀律
這就叫做計劃你的交易
交易你的計劃
另外還有一個
我自己一個很重要的一個原則
當然這是一個非常彈性的原則
叫做讓自己舒服
當一筆交易
也許你計劃的非常好
非常周密
行情也按照你的思路在走
但是有些行情會讓你的情緒不可控
也就是說要避免情緒影響智商
如果你發現這筆交易
這個市場的波動
已經讓你的情緒發生了波動的情況
那麼怎麼辦
如果是我的話
我就會讓自己舒服
把倉位降下來
或者實在不行
這筆交易就不做了
總而言之讓自己舒服
那麼很多時候
我前面也說了
很多時候交易上的成敗
不是說你的技巧
你的能力
你的知識
不是這些東西
重要的是你的心態
心態沒了
什麼都沒了
一定要有自己的方法
一定要到市場中去驗證自己的方法
只有賠錢了
才會認識到自己的方法錯了
而掙錢則是證明自己是對的
投機就是這樣
這段話也對也不對
我們不能簡單的說
賺錢的就是對的
虧錢的就是錯的
因為你不加上時間
不加上一個整個的一個邏輯在裡面的話
你失去這個前提
只看結果其實是不對的
我們不能以成敗論英雄
因為在投資市場上
在交易領域沒有絕對的對錯
你今天止損出來了
他明天大漲又回去了
你很難說你當時的判斷是正確還是錯誤的
但是有一點是肯定的
就是說任何人的方法理念
都是基於他自己的這個知識結構框架下的產物
他是有一個前提的
這個前提很重要
如果我不具備巴菲特那樣的知識結構的這種框架
那麼說實話
我們也就無法去踐行他的那個理念
因此投資交易其實是一個非常非常個人化
個性化的一件事情
所以說呢
要找到自己的niche
要找到自己的age
要找到自己的limit
其實非常重要
就是說你要有自己的比較優勢
你也要知道自己的認知侷限
這非常非常重要
一個能夠把自己的性格特徵
融合進去的投資方式
或者說是交易方法
那一定是最好的方法
就比如說我自己的方法
就是說雙均線系統
動態推演的這種方式
模糊正確的一種交易的態度
那這種東西
它是一個自成必還
它是符合我的個性
符合我的這種認知結構的
那麼這種東西
它就有點像是
長在你身體裡面的一種東西
它會逐漸地成為你的一種本能